The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open CourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right,
we're going to do two in a row.
And Kevin has got these.
So first we're going to do
a snapshot on, gee, could
the Defense Department--
you remember those guys,
with that connected model.
Could they play a role, here?
Is there something
useful they can do, here?
And then the second
is on this new RPG--
fairly new-- ARPA-E
model that's come about.
So this is Dorothy Robyn.
She was the former
Deputy Undersecretary
of Defense for something called
Facilities and Environment.
And she worked for,
you know, Ash Carter.
DOD had the largest--
it's the largest facilities
owner in the United States.
507 installations and
bases, 300,000 buildings,
2.2 billion square
feet of space.
That's interesting.
Right?
Maybe they're a test bed.
And, you know, they
do consume more oil
than anybody else in
the United States--
1.7%.
That's not a lot, but
still it's a lot of oil.
And they spend a lot
on energy every year.
So maybe they've got an
interest in some of this.
So, sure enough,
DOD actually thinks
it's got an energy problem--
for some pretty good reasons.
They understand that they
have a strategic problem
having to do with
worldwide energy supply.
The United States is profoundly
dependent on its oil supply.
And that is an
international market.
We probably spend a third
to a half of our defense
budget on protecting
what the military calls
their "lines of
communication" around oil--
i.e., their oil-supply system.
So, cleverly, the
oil industry has
managed to get the American
taxpayers to foot at least $250
billion a year, protecting
their supply system.
That's pretty clever-- a signal
of a politically powerful
legacy system.
So there is a deep strategic
problem around oil supply.
And then there's a profound
tactical set of problems that--
you know, they've been
engaged in two Middle Eastern
wars in the past decade, largely
around related to oil supply.
And their own
internal energy supply
lines created most
of their casualties.
Right?
That's why we lose people, in
these painful supply convoys.
It forces the army in particular
into a terrible tactical
position of having to
defend these fixed points
and concentrate forces to
defend these fixed points,
in an asymmetric war where
you don't want to have fixed
points.
You want to be part of
communities and populations.
So essentially the
oil-supply problem
has completely
counterdicted everything
the army knows
about how it should
fight asymmetric conflicts.
It's forced it into
offending long supply chains
to fixed points, which is
not a tactical position it
wants to be in.
And it's, in turn, forced
many casualties, as a result.
So the Army and the Marine Corps
wants to get out of this box.
They want more mobile, flexible,
tactically free forces,
to be able to sustain
the kind of models
they've developed for optimizing
their warfaring capabilities.
So they've got a strategic
problem, a tactical problem,
and then they've got a
big facilities problem.
DOD has lots of
aging, old facilities,
on old, long-established
bases, often built
in the World War II time period
or the Cold War time period.
They have been, for the last--
since the end of the Cold War--
under a significant
amount of cost pressure.
How can they get their
facilities' cost down?
So that's where
Dorothy Robyn, who
has the facilities
responsibility at DOD, where
she came in.
Interestingly, DOD every
year gets $20 billion
in something called "milcon"--
military construction.
That's for rehabbing,
repairing, upgrading,
and undertaking new construction
for its facilities and bases.
That's, like, a
guaranteed revenue stream.
And you can do a lot
of interesting things
with a pretty guaranteed
revenue stream.
So one of the things that
the Defense Department was
attempting to do is really
take advantage of this revenue
stream to do significant
facilities upgrades,
in terms of energy uses.
And so that was one of
her major projects, there.
So DOD could be a very
interesting testbed
and a very interesting
initial market for a suite
of new energy technologies.
Right?
So DOD Is not going to do carbon
capture and sequestration.
Right?
That's not its problem.
But it sure is interested
in getting off the grid.
Right?
It believes it has a
terrible cyber security
problem, by being on the grid.
It wants off.
It significantly wants to
reduce its energy costs.
It's ready to experiment
with renewables,
partly because of
the grid strategy,
probably to establish
more mobility
and get off fossil
fuels line of supplies.
It's got an incredible
number of vehicles,
both for military purposes
and unmilitary purposes.
That again is another
testbed opportunity.
So the idea here, as
her testimony laid out,
to one of the
armed-services committees,
is that DOD actually
could be a partner
in an energy-technology
strategy,
as a demonstration and
testbed kind of center
and an opportunity to introduce
certain kinds of new energy
technologies.
Huge interest in
batteries, for example.
So ARPA-E was a
gap-filling attempt.
The Department of Energy
innovation system,
it's kind of what it looked
like before ARPA-E came along.
Right?
The red stuff is the new stuff.
The black and white
slides or boxes
are what was there before.
So, before the
new stuff arrived,
the Department of Energy had
big, fundamental research
organization, very
basic research
in areas like particle
physics and chemistry.
Famous Vannevar Bush
basic research entity--
the DOE Office of Science.
The great bulk of the
energy laboratories
reported through the
DOE Office of Science.
They took up about 60% of
DOE Office of Science budget.
It was about $5 billion a year.
The energy labs-- one
of the largest armies
PhDs in the world.
Right?
An incredible 12,000 army--
great majority, physicists.
There may be some
engineers in there.
It was on the wrong problem.
Right?
It was on the historical
nuclear-weapons problem.
So, of the 14 energy labs, the
nuclear-weapons laboratories
had about 5,000 of
that army of PhDs.
The NREL laboratory,
renewable-energy laboratory,
had 340 of the PhDs.
Right?
You can see what the
imbalance here is.
It's not the right lineup.
So it was kind of,
a lot of the talent
was on the wrong set
of issues-- or at least
not the new set of issues.
There was an energy-efficiency
and renewable-energy entity,
had about a $2 billion budget.
There was some other
applied-energy offices.
That was the landscape.
And then a huge
nuclear security kind
of weapons-oriented part and a
big cleanup, nuclear-cleanup,
part of the department.
That was kind of the department.
Something that happened
under Sam Bodman and then
Steve Chu and then
Ernie Moniz is
that that whole picture of that
department got reorganized.
One of those pieces was
ARPA-E. We'll come back
to this slide in a minute.
ARPA-E was organized to
bring a DARPA-like model--
a breakthrough energy research--
into a structure
that didn't do that.
Right?
The applied agencies
worked primarily
with established industry.
There was nobody really working
on the breakthrough side.
So, if you happened
to think that you
need a lot of breakthrough
energy technologies
to solve the climate
problem, you probably
need something like this.
So an interesting
process got put together,
to get that assembled.
You know, Max, you asked a
very good question earlier--
how come it's only $300 million,
when DARPA's $3 billion?
Those of us who were involved
in advocating and supporting
the legislation, we wanted a
much larger budget, frankly,
a $1-billion kind of
budget for ARPA-E--
and have never politically
been able to get there.
But, nonetheless, I would
argue that ARPA-E has actually
been a pretty remarkably
successful entity.
So ARPA-E does all
this stuff that we've
talked about for DARPA.
It's got that model down--
flat, nonhierarchical,
empowered program managers.
They're called
"project directors."
Streamlined approval
process for both hiring
and for contracting.
It's right-left.
It's challenge-based.
It only wants to
do breakthroughs.
It's not going to
do incremental work.
It uses island/bridge.
In fact, Arun Majumdar, who
was the first head of ARPA-E,
who's one of the most talented
science leaders I've ever
seen--
remarkably talented
guy-- he had been--
Steve Chu, the
energy secretary--
he'd been Steve Chu's deputy at
Lawrence Berkeley Laboratory.
So, when Arun moved
to Washington,
he lived in Steve Chu's
basement for six months.
So there was no
island/bridge problem there.
Right?
[LAUGH] You know, they
were only a floor away.
There was extremely good
communication between the two.
That's the best island/bridge
example I know of.
[LAUGH] So I try to bring it up.
But, interestingly,
ARPA-E, it didn't
have that connected energy
system for innovation.
Right?
Because the Department of Energy
doesn't do any procurement.
They don't buy batteries.
They don't buy electric cars.
You know, they don't
buy this stuff.
So DOD buys their first
round of products.
It can be an initial
market creator.
That's one of the
advantages DARPA's got.
How does ARPA-E
function, when it
doesn't have that follow-on
capability embedded
in the department,
which it's located?
So it's had to come up with a
whole bunch of new approaches
that have really been
quite interesting.
And I list some of
them in this piece
that I did with a friend and
a DARPA expert, Dick VanAtta.
They did a lot of
work on how to sharpen
their research-visioning
process.
They definitely followed that
research-visioning model.
It's not only, is this
a cool technology,
but is this a technology
that is not only
potentially a breakthrough,
but could it actually scale up?
Is it plausible-- do we
have a plausible pathway,
by which this technology could
come into the marketplace?
And that's definitely part
of the research visioning
that ARPA-E undertakes, in a
way that DARPA doesn't really
have to because it's got
military customers often.
It's done a remarkable job at
building a support community.
So ARPA-E, just
for one example, it
does what's now become probably
the most important US energy
technology summit every year.
They get 2,000 to 3,000
people showing up at this.
Every major energy firm,
every venture-capital firm,
they're all there for,
like, a three-day session.
They have great speakers--
and amazing technology.
In other words, if you
do technology for ARPA-E,
it's going to get showcased.
It's going to get presented
to this energy world.
It's going to be shown off.
They're going to help
you take that next step.
And, interestingly,
in the first summit,
when they put out their first,
you know, offer of-- you know,
for proposals--
which didn't specify areas
they wanted to research in;
they just had an open proposal.
Hi, energy community,
out there--
send us your best stuff--
they expected to get
about 400 proposals.
Instead, they got 4,000.
Right?
Because there was
so much interest
in working with a
DARPA-like thing.
So they were drowning.
They had to invent
a whole review
process, to manage all that.
But, interestingly--
and they could only
approve a modest number.
But they invited all
the best proposals--
a much larger number--
to show up to their
first summit and present.
Which helped build a community.
You know, the
community felt, hey,
these guys are going
to look out for us.
And it created a whole
community interest
in what this thing was going to
be that has been really quite
successful.
So they've got a strong
support community
in the venture-capital
community.
They've got strong
university support.
They've got
established companies
that are working with DARPA--
supported research and firms.
It's pretty interesting.
The most interesting
thing they've been doing
is on the
technology-implementation side.
And here, they created their
own commercialization team.
So there are these project
managers, and they--
you know, they're empowered,
DARPA-like project managers.
But, on their team,
they pull in somebody
from ARPA-E's
commercialization group.
And these are people
with, like, expertise
in getting venture capital and
commercializing technology.
They know how larger firms do
technology commercialization.
They even have somebody who's
expert at military contracting,
so you might sell
it to a DOD market.
The commercialization
team has a member that's
part of the technology group.
Right?
So commercialization is
thought through from the outset
of an ARPA-E technology project.
Because, again, they don't have
this big procurement budget.
They've got to find more
creative ways around it.
And the greatest compliment so
far to ARPA-E and its success--
DARPA has now copied the model.
So, like, the parent has
now copied the child.
And DARPA, earlier this
year-- or last year--
hired ARPA-E's head of
their commercialization team
to set up a commercialization
team at DARPA.
So, interesting.
Right?
So those are some of the efforts
that ARPA-E has been making.
And Kevin and I were
talking, earlier,
but ARPA:E did a very thorough,
tough-minded evaluation of all
of its research budgets and
then issued reports in August
and September.
And it's a pretty
fascinating story.
You know, as we know
from this class--
and Kevin and I were
just talking about this--
technology standup
takes a long time.
Right?
1947, we do the first
mainframe computer.
You know, 1993, the internet and
desktop computing are scaling.
That's a long time.
Right?
Fracking happened a lot faster
than most technology standups.
That was a 15-year project.
It's paradigm-compatible
with the legacy sector,
so that helped, but that
was still a 15-year project.
So seven years is much
too short a timetable
to be evaluating whether
these energy technologies are
going to scale.
But, in terms of
technology advance,
and in terms of attracting
additional funding from
nongovernmental sources, ARPA-E
has had a very good track
record--
as evidenced in these
August and September reports
they've put out.
All right.
All yours, sir.
MARTHA: Can I just
ask a question?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Please.
MARTHA: Didn't they announce
that basically the companies
had attracted about as much
outside funding as they had
spent since our ARPA-E began?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
And that was composed of two
sources-- other federal R&D,
or--
MARTHA: OK, OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: --financial
support from allied companies
or from venture-capital firms.
And we're going to talk about
the venture-capital model
in a bit.
MARTHA: OK.
Sorry for interrupting.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No, but
it was a good point to make.
Thank you, Martha.
KEVIN: OK, so, going back to
the testimony by Dr. Robyn,
she stated that all
these critical facilities
that the DOD depends on
for running operations
across the board
are so vulnerable.
Why did they let it
get to such a point
where, you know, someone
needs to tell them,
like, hey, you know, we should
innovate in this regard,
to prevent all that
from happening.
And, taking those
lessons learned,
how should the DOD
or any department
really prioritize any proposals
that come forward to it?
PERSON: Do you mind
rephrasing the question?
KEVIN: Yeah.
So she said these critical
systems are really vulnerable.
Here's my proposal.
In the future, or
in anyone's opinion,
how should any department
and particularly the DOD
prioritize its resources, based
on these proposals that they
get, in order to prevent such
vulnerabilities from occurring?
STEPH: I can't
imagine that this was
published without some of those
vulnerabilities being patched.
MARTHA: What do you
mean by "patched"?
STEPH: Like, it does not occur
to me that the government would
allow-- or, you know,
the-- what is she--
the Deputy Undersecretary
of Defense--
MARTHA: To publicly--
STEPH: --to publicly announce
that these vulnerabilities
exist within their system,
in their infrastructure,
without them first
being patched.
Right?
And I know that a lot--
could you talk a little
bit about that, Bill?
Because--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, I mean, she's--
STEPH: --it says that
it's hold until released.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
She's testifying in front of
the Armed Services Committee,
and they want to
know what's going on.
And a witness has
got an obligation
to come forward with what
the state of affairs is.
You know I don't think these
were probably classified--
I know these weren't
classified issues, because this
was an open hearing.
But she's got a responsibility,
as a governmental official,
to tell a congressional
committee what
in fact is going on and what the
issues and vulnerabilities are.
So I think she's doing her job,
and the congressional committee
is doing its job.
It's got to probe and find
out what the problems are.
I'm not sure that's a great
answer to your question.
STEPH: I guess-- does that not--
I guess, to follow
up, would that not
set us up for more
vulnerabilities,
if we openly acknowledge
that that's something
that we're concerned about?
Just-- and would
it not be a problem
that we will find
ourselves more into,
if we admit to such
vulnerabilities
in a public setting?
MARTHA: Maybe it's
already obvious,
if it's been in the
press, et cetera.
People dying-- yeah.
STUDENT: And then what they
do is particularly surprising.
STEPH: I don't
disagree, but I think
it's different to have a deputy
undersecretary admitting it--
is my point.
KEVIN: I think, following
up on that, if, you know,
it's not a surprise
to anyone, why
are other projects prioritized
over preventing this
from happening?
If it's like, oh, well,
of course, they're
vulnerable to cyber attacks,
and these facilities
are falling apart.
You know, we were just talking
about, the dependence on oil
causing a lot of problems.
Why not innovate in that area?
STUDENT: Well, I think part of
it goes back to the funding,
from that graph.
You remember that graph, the
graph about funding and oil
prices that [INAUDIBLE]
follow the same trend?
So, like, if funding
isn't really steady,
you can't really
innovate very well.
It's hard to
maintain facilities.
KEVIN: But you said
they get a $20 billion--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: They do
have an annual $20-billion
military-construction
appropriation
that's potentially an
interesting revenue stream that
you could finance off of.
STUDENT: But that's just DOD.
Like, other departments, they
still have these problems.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right, But
DOD is the monster in the room.
They're the ones that
really have the facilities.
STUDENT: Also, I wonder
about the distribution
of the quality, I guess, in
facilities or infrastructure.
So I can imagine, not all
these 300,000 buildings
are really falling
apart and in disrepair.
But I think maybe
it's just, they
don't like that there are
a number of buildings sort
of on this lighter end of--
kind of built in
World War II-esque,
and they haven't really been
upgraded from a construction
or systems point of view.
And I would argue that,
like, the $20 billion
or however they're
getting yearly
to upgrade these services is
adequate or kind of serving
them well, such that those
are-- like, that's your patch.
And it's not really an issue of
national security, in a sense,
because this is a distributed
problem, kind of over the DOD
network, rather than,
like, all right,
all of our systems in Virginia
or in this particular area
are subject to cyber
attack and are vulnerable.
It seems like-- like, it's
too big of a problem for it
to be actual information
for her, you know,
not to be able to
testify about it.
This isn't a
national-security interest,
in that it has to be protected.
STEPH: Yeah.
And, to your point about
the size of the budget,
I'm looking at the 2017 report
on infrastructure management,
from the Government
Accountability Office.
And it says that they expect
the DOD estimated replacement
value to be $880 billion.
So.
That's a--
STUDENT: What do you mean
by "replacement value"?
STEPH: Well, that's
what they're-- for the
infrastructure, for the DOD,
that they need to improve
[INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: That's a lot of money.
[LAUGHTER]
So that was just--
I guess that was just
released for fiscal year 2017.
STUDENT: Yeah.
I mean, I don't think
it's too much an issue
that they released this.
There's this other thing
called Zero Days, which
is actually things
that you can hack
into infrastructure systems.
And that's more serious.
What they do is, they will
report it to the agency.
And, because they know
agencies will get lazy,
if you say you're not going
to do anything they say,
I'll give you x amount of time
until I do report it publicly.
And I think this was an
issue that they already
knew it was OK to say publicly.
And so I'm not too
concerned with that.
On the issue of actual,
oh, this is a problem,
I think it's just more
that it's a big government.
There's a lot of problems.
And there isn't really
going to be-- you know,
nothing's going to be perfect.
And so they're just trying
to bring light to it,
so they can put funds to it.
And things do
precipitate, especially
with organizations where--
I mean, this happens
with people all the time.
Right?
You really don't know
what you're going
to do, like, a day from now.
Right?
Or a lot of things will
add up, and they'll
get past saturation points.
And it's also just
a big legacy sector,
so there is going to be issues.
AUDIENCE: Didn't
you ask the question
of how should they prioritize?
KEVIN: [INAUDIBLE]
MARTHA: Yeah.
KEVIN: [LAUGH] You know,
where should those $20 billion
go, every year?
MARTHA: Mhm?
WOMAN: I just think it's
hard, because, to most people,
$20 billion seems like it
could solve a lot of problems.
Like, that seems
like a lot of money.
But, I guess, when you spread
it across all the facilities
that they have, to
make a real impact
you really need to pick
specific things to focus on.
And then, I think, a lot of
politics can come into, like,
who's getting the money and
how they're allocating it,
because there's not enough for
every base to get an upgrade.
And so I'm sure that's
an additional challenge.
STEPH: The report says
562,000 facilities worldwide,
at 4,800 sites.
So that's steep.
STUDENT: $20 billion?
STEPH: Yeah.
STUDENT: It's not
too much money.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Kevin,
how about a closing thought
on Dorothy Robyn's testimony?
KEVIN: Well, I'm curious to see
how the proposal she laid out
has progressed since
it was made in 2012.
I would hope that more
people bring attention
to this-- like,
hey, you know, we
should innovate in these other
things that aren't just, like,
weapons.
Because the development
of other projects
depends on the development
of those, as well.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And I think it's fair to say
that she and colleagues at DOD
actually made significant
progress in using
these facilities as, in effect,
test beds and demonstration
centers for new technologies.
And, because this is
essentially cost-saving and
security-related issues,
there's good reason
to think that, under the new
administration, a lot of this
will continue.
Let me turn to the ARPA-E piece.
Questions for us, on that one?
KEVIN: So, you know,
since you said they just
released a report, analyzing
[INAUDIBLE] projects
on the research and the
relative success of that,
and because we have evidence
files [INAUDIBLE] DARPA
has been, why don't
we really hear
about any other DARPA qualms?
You know, they mentioned that
the Department of Education was
considering ARPA-E, that the NIH
was considering their research
models depending on--
[LAUGH] that sort
of mimic DARPA.
Why aren't innovation
models like
the ones in DARPA and ARPA-E
being utilized in other fields?
STUDENT: It's possible that--
this is just an opinion, and I
have no facts to back it up--
but--
[LAUGHTER]
--it's possible that maybe
some of the challenges that
are solved by DARPA and
ARPA-E, they don't necessarily
translate as well
to social problems,
like Department of Education.
So with education, it's
less of a technical problem.
And maybe a lot of it's more,
how do we manage people,
how do we determine what's a
good versus a bad student, good
versus bad teacher, et cetera.
So I'm not sure if
it would fit as well.
Again, opinion.
KEVIN: To add, I think
education in particular
would also be considered
a legacy sector.
And to stand up, you know, a
DARPA-like model for education
would be to completely
undermine the education
system in the United States.
And that would require
the undertaking
of not only the education system
in terms of national standards
but also a reframing
fundamentally
at the state level of the ways
in which we conduct education
policy.
And that, I think, from a
reframing the conversation
nationally, would be
an immensely difficult
undertaking.
It would be politically--
I mean, I don't know if
"politically unviable" is
the right word,
but it seems to me
like it would be
politically insurmountable.
Because you're now threatening,
you know, states' rights.
PERSON: Why does it--
why is it an undermining of the
education system I mean, the--
STEPH: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
PERSON: --defense system.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let
me just give a little bit
of background, because I was
involved in some of this.
And it never happened.
And Congress was never
interested in funding in it.
And part of it was, you know,
what does the Department
of Education--
which is essentially
an entitlement-administration
organization--
what do they know about
technology policy in education?
Right?
But, with the development
of online capability
and computer-gaming
technologies,
a whole new raft of
technology options
has entered the education field.
So there was a fair amount
of thinking that maybe there
was room for a
technology-breakthrough entity
in the education space.
The education space
is also notorious
for conducting
almost no R&D. Right?
Almost zero.
Right?
It's tragic.
KEVIN: I would--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
And how are you
going to transform a
sector without, you know,
undertaking technology
development and research
and development on it?
So, agree, it's
threatening, right?
Online education
and blended learning
are threatening models
to establish systems--
no question about it.
But this was actually, I
think, an interesting idea.
The problem was, who's going
to find the right technology
crowd that would really create
the kind of breakthroughs
that a DARPA-like
entity could do?
And I think that was
more of the challenge.
KEVIN: And you're saying
it's making threats
to establish education models.
Is that necessarily a bad
thing, wherein, you know,
we see the US rankings
are way below--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No, I'm not
saying it's a bad thing at all.
I think the whole system
needs to be changed.
But I agree with you, Kevin.
And this would be a tool
to try some of that with.
STUDENT: And it's the
big disruption thing.
It's like-- it's like Uber.
So imagine, like, if you really
affect the teachers' jobs,
there's all these unions.
Right?
So, like, now a kid
can go and, like,
he doesn't-- he still
needs a teacher,
but now you've kind of made
them very uncomfortable.
So you can get the
amount of push-back.
So, when you create
this system, you
have to figure out
how you're going
to make it so that the
teacher doesn't feel offended.
I mean, Kahn Academy did
a really good job of this,
of, like, OK, well, now you
can spend your time doing
what you do, in the classroom.
But even then, how are you
going to get mass support?
And I still don't know what
their numbers are like.
STUDENT: Why is the
kid uncomfortable?
STUDENT: Not the
kid, the teacher.
Because there's unions.
So this is especially
important in, like, the--
Steve Case, the
guy who made AOL.
He made a book called The Third
Wave, which is, like, you know,
the internet entrepreneurs
that will affect
physical structures and not
just web 2.0 that is on Facebook
and Snapchat, the people
that would create systems
that interact with
people like Uber,
they don't just
make a technology.
They have to focus on the
legacy history of the people
in that organization.
So, when you make
an Uber, you have
to worry about the taxi-cab
drivers who paid $1 million
for a medallion.
And this is how they're
supporting themselves,
and now you're
going to disrupt it.
And also, what's going to
happen to these drivers?
What about union problems?
How do you ensure safety, as
there's been several concerns.
So it's not a tech--
These aren't-- I think
for DARPA and ARPA-E,
there's a technology issue.
Let's do the technology.
For these issues,
it's more of a,
this is very much a
people technology.
Right?
Like-- And most politicians--
Michael Bloomberg, Bill
Gates, who's a billionaire,
which you all know--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: But,
Martn, there still have been--
look, I mean, how many
technological disruptions
of education have there been?
I mean, we came up with the
printing press in, what, 1562?
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
That was a big one.
Books-- we figured out books.
That's about it.
Right?
That's pretty much the change.
So applying this whole new
information-technology online
world to the education system,
those are profound technology--
and, I agree, social
and learning challenges
go with those.
And they are threatening
to establish communities.
I agree completely.
But I do think,
interestingly, certainly
for the first time
in my lifetime,
I've seen an opportunity for
significant technology entry
into a classic legacy sector.
And so the idea of putting a
DARPA-like thing around that,
that was an interesting idea.
Right?
It just hasn't happened.
STUDENT: I think I'm
going to push back
on this a little bit--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Please.
STUDENT: --the idea
that education doesn't
have a DARPA-like model.
Like, the rise of
charter schools, I think,
has really disrupted how
we think about the system
of public education.
And you used to really just
have public versus private,
but now you have private
and, like, quasi public
charter schools that receive
federal and state funding
but, like, do state testing
but don't do some other things.
And they have the
elements that you
think you get in a public
education, which is, like,
the group environment, but
they focus their classes
and they structure
them differently
and they do a whole
bunch of other stuff,
because they don't
have to adhere
to kind of all of
the regulations that
come from the state and
the federal government.
And so I would say
that education has--
it's like a distributed--
it is a distributed system,
because it gets, like,
more state by state
than, like, really
the Federal Department
of Education-mandated things.
But also, in charter schools
and things like this,
you have opportunities for
different models that are--
like, people are
already testing out,
and you're already seeing
this disruption that Martn is
talking about, where you
have these entrenched
public-education systems, but
now you're having this rival
charter school that now
comes in and kind of disrupts
teachers' unions and
things like that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All
right, so I'm going to-- you
know, I'm going to halt
our education discussion.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
Because we're going to have
a whole class, next week,
on education.
So we can pursue this at length.
This is kind of a breath
of what's to come,
in next week's experiment.
But, Kevin, why don't you
close out our ARPA-E discussion
with--
maybe summarize what you
thought some of the key points
are about ARPA-E?
KEVIN: It's still growing.
I think-- well, it might not
be growing [LAUGH] anymore.
But it's a good proof of concept
that the DARPA model and models
like it are good change
agents, when they're needed.
Especially in a really
established legacy sector
like energy is.
My personal opinion-- I'd like
to see these kind of models
applied elsewhere.
You know, I was reading,
here, that Homeland Security
intelligence and others were
planning their own ARPA models.
And, even on smaller scales, I
feel like this innovation model
could be really beneficial.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Good.
OK.
STUDENT: I have
one more question,
because we were talking about
innovation organizations.
I was wondering if
there was an innovation
organization for
manufacturing, because that's
a focus of yours.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: There are
these brand-new manufacturing
institutes.
And there's 14 of these.
And they are organized around
major technology challenges
in the manufacturing space.
STUDENT: Could you specify?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So, 3D printing.
You know, what technology
advances are we going to get
out of that, whether it's--
there's an institute
around tissue engineering
and regenerative medicine.
There's an institute
around photonics.
around power electronics
and wideband-gap semiconductors.
There's an institute
around advanced composites.
So, in 14 different
interesting technology areas
that could be quite powerful,
across a range of manufacturing
sectors, we are attempting
an innovation model.
It's a public-private
collaboration.
STUDENT: So they try to do best
practices in standardization?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, no, they're
attempting to do
technology development.
So, TRA level--
TRL levels 4 through 7, kind of,
mid- to later-stage technology
development efforts, tying
that to the communities that
would have to be involved
if these models are
going to get picked up.
So it's an interesting-- it's
the first attempt, really,
in the US, other than SEMATECH,
to bring an innovation model
to the manufacturing sector.
STUDENT: Do these
manufacturing institutes
follow one general
innovation model?
Or does each one
cater to whatever--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Each one is--
they share a lot
of similarities.
They're all cost-share.
They involve small
and large firms.
They involve university
with strong technology
and engineering programs.
They involve community colleges.
They have
workforce-development model.
So they share those pieces.
But then the particular
technology area
they're pursuing means
they're going to be
organized somewhat differently.
So the one MIT is leading,
on revolutionary fibers,
that's got a different approach
and a different kind of sector,
frankly, than the
composite sector.
So it's an interesting
attempt to bring innovation
into a long-standing legacy
sector where the federal
innovation system never
really played any role--
except for SEMATECH.
So let me turn to this
kind of Plan B idea.
The idea here was,
you know, we're
not going to do a cap-and-trade
proposal anytime soon.
So what do we do?
You know, what's the menu of
options, if we actually want
to deal with climate change?
And one of the
problems-- look, I
was involved in drafting the
original Senate climate-change
legislation.
And one of the problems
in that legislation
was, we were attempting
an economy-wide fix,
based upon a neoclassical
economic concept
that you could alter
prices and drive change.
And it turned out to be
more complicated than that.
Right?
First of all, it's hard to get
an economy-wide model imposed.
It's hard to nail
everybody at the same time.
Right?
The political system
tends to resist this.
In economic terms,
it's very interesting
to impose an economy-wide
model, but it's hard.
And then, secondly--
well, I had actually
worked on the original
acid-rain provisions
the Clean Air Act
of 1990, legislation
to develop a cap-and-trade
system there.
It worked brilliantly, and
it was a stalking horse
for what we knew we were going
to do on the climate layer.
And cap-and-trade worked
brilliantly, there.
It worked brilliantly, because
we already had the technology
solutions at hand.
They could be the
scrubbers that we
were going to put on smokestacks
in Midwestern power plants.
We knew the
technology was there.
So a pricing system could
really drive, very quickly,
the forced adoption
of that technology.
When we did cap-and-trade,
it took us a while
to understand that a lot of the
technologies were not close.
They were still a
considerable distance away.
We've talked about carbon
capture and sequestration.
It's a good example.
Right?
It's not ready for deployment
at large scale, at this point.
It's still experimental.
So it wasn't a great fit.
So obviously the
industries that were
going to be affected
by this, they
didn't know what their
pathways were going to be,
in many cases.
Right?
And, look, in many
sectors, look at transport.
We don't know if it's
going to be biofuels.
going to be electrics.
We don't know if it's
going to be hybrids.
We don't know what it's
going to-- or maybe just
significant improvements to
internal combustion engines.
All those pieces are still
very much on the table,
in the transport
sector-- obviously
a huge economic sector.
So one of the problems with
cap-and-trade and neoclassical
model was that it didn't have
a sophisticated understanding
of the technology policy side.
And I wish I had
understood that then, but--
WOMAN: [LAUGH]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
--and obviously I
wasn't the only actor.
And, overall, I think
a price solution
is going to be needed, here.
But meanwhile, can
we make progress?
So part of the way in
which we can make progress
is by a considerably more
sophisticated and effective
technology strategy.
After this book was--
after the book that this
chapter appeared in was written,
obviously there was a
major political change
in the United States.
So the changes
we're going to have
to think about, if we're
going to do a Plan B
and I just sit on our
hands for the next decade,
I think that's a
really important task.
And we're going to have to
think about who the actors are
going to be that are prepared
to take on climate change.
Because we can't just
afford to wipe off
4, 8, 10 years of progress.
We've got to figure
out what to do so.
There's a new menu of
actors, here, that's
potential-- at state level, and
in regions, and in companies.
Because I do think this
innovation wave is under way.
And Martn's point
about niche players,
that's an important
economic point.
You can move ahead with
that kind of approach,
in a number of technology spots.
So, arguably, we're
going to need a Plan B,
and we're going to have to think
about who the actors are going
to be in Plan B. One
thing which we did
do in the Department of
Energy, over the last 10 years,
is make it a much
more sophisticated
technology-implementation
organization,
through work of Sam
Bodman and Steve Chu
and Ernie Moniz over
the past decade.
So all these new pieces,
including ARPA-E,
Energy Frontier
Research Centers,
to kind of turn the focus
of the Office of Science
onto new energy
technology advances.
There's 45 of these centers,
now, at universities
across the country.
Office of Science is
now really focused
on new technology advances.
EERE, Energy Efficiency
and Renewable Energy,
has developed a major focus
on advanced manufacturing
as a way of driving down
entry costs for new energy
technologies.
That's really
important, if they're
going to get in range of price.
They've created something we'll
talk about in the last reading.
They have created a whole new
way of getting, in effect,
substituting space for
capital, at the site of three
historic energy laboratories.
We'll talk about in
the last reading.
They have a much stronger
technology-transition office.
They have innovation hubs
that, when your technology is
ready to kind of scale
up, you can actually
get a substantial
amount of implementation
and late-stage applied
research money focused
on areas like batteries,
fourth-generation nuclear
power, and a series of
other technology areas.
So all these new
innovation pieces
have been added to the
Department of Energy.
So it's much more
technology-ready
than it was a decade ago.
It's much more in position to
be able to work on the energy
tasks that it was assigned.
So that's--
Obviously, these
could be curtailed
by the current administration.
That's a genuine
challenge, here.
But at least we've
got experience now
with what some of
these issues are.
There's still big
gaps in the system.
The front end is
much better now,
at the Department of
Energy, but there's still
big gaps-- areas like,
how do you do test beds?
How are we going to do a
technology strategy that
cuts across public
and private sectors,
for a common strategy
across players?
We haven't done that yet.
We need new financing mechanisms
for technology implementation.
So there's a lot
of pieces that--
there still remain gaps on
the back end of the system.
But we have made progress.
And, look, let me put the
other piece on the table
and we'll do them both.
Are both of these yours, Chris?
CHRIS: Yep.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: OK.
So this is a chapter in a piece
that just came out last month.
The US is very reliant on
entrepreneurial startups
to bring innovation
into its system.
That's been a key innovation
organizational accomplishment
of the last 30 or
40 years, actually.
So we developed a $60-billion
venture-capital support system
to support startups.
It's how we do it.
It's a very interesting
part of our system.
No other country really has
a system as strong as ours.
The legacy sectors are
like protected castles.
VCs don't like to
take the castles on.
You can understand why.
They like to innovate in
new frontier areas, where
there are not incumbents,
where they're not
going to get opposition.
So, back in 2008, when it looked
like energy prices were going
to be high and cap-and-trade
was coming along,
VCs began to ramp
up their investments
in new energy technologies.
And they've now walked.
So let's look at venture-capital
investment, nationwide.
This is what venture
capital spent in 2015
its money on-- its $60 billion.
Right?
Software.
That's the long and short of it.
They did a fair
amount of biotech.
Software was about 40%.
That's about 13%.
A bunch of services,
media entertainment,
IT services-- that was
the bulk of the rest.
Now, you look at this
little piece down here,
right, this piece.
That's 5%.
That's hard technologies.
That's energy and industrial.
Right?
This has profound
implications, absolutely
profound implications.
So the way in which we
stand up new innovation
is going to be through this
venture-capital finance system.
And all they're going to
do is software and biotech
and a few services.
We've got a serious
problem on our hands.
We're not going to have an
energy-technology revolution.
But we're also not
standing up innovations
in hard technologies.
Software and biotech
are not particularly
job-creating areas.
Software maybe
negative job creating.
Right?
Are we going to have any
jobs, in this economy?
I mean, what's going
to happen, here?
These are really,
really serious problems.
OK?
We tried to do the
same chart for 2016,
but [LAUGH] the Venture
Capital Association [LAUGH]
changed the way they collected
their numbers, because software
was so pervasive that they
couldn't separate it out
anymore [LAUGH].
Right?
It was in every sector.
So [LAUGH] 15 is
the last good set
of numbers we're going to get
around software investment.
So, who comes to
the rescue, here?
So Rafael comes to the rescue.
I didn't get this.
I mean, this is his thinking.
And I had this
conversation with him.
We had been
struggling with this,
in the Advanced
Manufacturing Partnership
program, the President's
advanced manufacturing
innovation effort.
How are we going
to get financing
for companies that are going
to manufacture in the United
States?
Because they're not
getting venture finance.
And we looked at the
other potential sources--
you know, private equity, M&A
in existing company financing.
They're just not significant
for innovative new companies.
Venture capital is
pretty much the story.
And, you know, Rafael--
I was thinking
about, how could we
do some kind of new
financing, or how could we
create incentives for venture
capital to change all its rules
and go after these
harder problems?
He basically said, venture
capital is doing good stuff.
Software and biotech
are important things.
They're going to do
what they can do.
Substitute space for capital.
That wasn't quite
the way he put it,
but that was the essence
of what he was saying.
And I said, Rafael, what
are you talking about?
Never had dawned on me.
Right?
Basically what he said
was, let's create really
technology-equipment,
know-how-rich spaces and get
a bunch of very interesting
hard-technology startups--
in other words, the
biotechs are OK,
and the software
companies are OK.
Let's get some of the
rest of the crew in
and create places where they
get really advanced equipment
and know-how.
Right?
So there's a lot of technology
incubators out there,
and we've got
probably eight of them
right in our Boston
neighborhood, here,
and some of which
are very strong.
They tend to be earlier-stage.
They tend to-- they
capture you when you're new
and you're really at
the business-plan,
business-development
kind of stage.
There isn't really
a model to help you,
when you've got to
start to scale up--
and with that
scale-up proposition.
So that's what his concept is.
And it happens to speak,
I think profoundly,
to this energy-technology
space, if we
could create some of these.
The engine that he's
now led the creation of
is exactly an attempt
to solve this problem.
In other words,
his view is, we're
leading a lot of science-based
innovation developed in MIT,
just sitting on the table.
Because we don't have
a scale-up mechanism.
Can we work on trying to create
a space where that could occur?
So, in effect, what venture
capital would finance--
that equipment, that
technology, that know-how,
for the scale-up--
can we contribute
that, create that,
and then invite the
startups in that are
doing hard-technology startups?
So there's a bunch
of other models.
DOE got this, big-time.
ARPA-E began
running into a wall.
ARPA-E had assumed
venture capital
was the way in which its
startups were going to work.
And then they realized their
startups weren't getting
venture money, when
venture-capital funding
in energy collapsed-- right?
Went down 80%.
So this band of characters
took some space right
at the Lawrence
Berkeley Laboratory,
up on top of the hill, up
above the Berkeley campus,
on Cyclotron Road.
And they created a
technology, equipment,
know-how-rich space
and provided salaries--
for a couple of years,
which could be extended--
for a crew of startups.
They're now in
their third tranche.
Very interesting.
Very interesting companies.
And it's a whole new
technology transition model
for the Department of Energy.
So, for possibly 40 years,
the Department of Energy
has been trying to get
these big, famous energy
laboratories that are on
mesas, behind barbed wire,
to transfer their
technology out.
And the folks that work
there are paid, you know,
guaranteed salaries for life.
And they get
entitlement-funded research.
They're guaranteed
interesting scientific work.
And we want them to
walk out of there
and, you know, not be paid
in a stand-up company?
I mean, good luck.
Right?
It's not an optimal
technology transfer model.
And, look-- technology transfers
with people that walk, right?
Technology transfer
doesn't happen
by developing a list or a plan
and handing it to someone.
Technology transfer
works through people.
You've got to really encourage
people to emigrate and move
with the ideas, because they
have the tacit knowledge
to make these things happen.
Well, this may be a much better
technology-transfer model
for the Department of
Energy than the one they've
been working on for 40 years.
So two other labs,
Argon and Oak Ridge,
have now picked
up the same model.
Steph?
STEPH: One of the
elements I didn't
see in the analysis
of the models
was the importance
of competition
or having that sort of
truncated time frame.
How is it that they sort of put
pressure on them to deliver?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well all of these teams
had to compete, to get in there.
So that was a very
tough composition--
more than 100 actors,
100 different teams,
were competing to be
part of the first eight.
So that was a highly
competitive process.
Look, if you've got an
interesting startup idea
and you're just out of grad
school or, for that matter,
just out of undergrad
school, and you've
got a really interesting,
small group and idea
and you want to
move it, the fact
that somebody would give you
space, incredible equipment,
and technology,
incredible know-how,
and pay you a salary
for a couple of years,
what could be better?
Right?
This is really good news,
for hard-technology startups
in the energy space.
So it's been very
attractive, and there's
a lot of competition to
get into these places.
So competition is embedded
right at the heart of the model.
Martha?
MARTHA: So, Bill, do
you have any sense--
well, first of all, I can't
remember how old they are
and what kind of track record
they have, at this point in--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
these are all brand-new.
This is a brand-new model.
Right?
MARTHA: Cyclotron--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So they just accepted
their third round of teams.
So they're two years old.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
OK.
I wasn't really clear.
So are they going to
be able to expand,
under this new political
climate, to other labs?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We'll see.
I think-- from the sense I have
in talking to DOE friends--
what's wrong with this model?
I mean, you're in effect
repurposing an established
model at extremely modest costs.
MARTHA: Right.
So, in other words--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Lawrence Berkeley
Lab's an $800-million-a-year
operation.
You know, salaries,
for these folks?
That's not much.
Right?
And yet the opportunities
of standing up
with new technologies are
really pretty significant,
supporting entrepreneurs.
So I think this one
is a viable model,
in either political climate.
PERSON: Right, so who
makes the decision?
And what stage is the
technology, when they enter?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So, you know, this guy,
Ilan Gur is right out of ARPA-E.
So he's very used to-- he
understands really well--
he came through a whole
startup experience, himself.
He's had startup experiences
and has his PhD in science,
from Berkeley--
very talented
young technologist,
very sharp, able guy.
He's got a whole team, there,
that's also quite able.
And strong support from the lab.
Right?
So the lab likes this.
This is a way of
getting their stuff out.
Look-- it's a new model, right?
The model is, have a
competition for, an effect,
a nerd motorcycle gang.
Park them outside
the barbed wire.
Give them a home, and give
them the keys to go in
and loot the place.
I mean, that's
essentially the model.
Right?
That's what they're doing.
PERSON: So, when you say
"park them outside the fence,"
is that literal?
Or--
STEPH: Yeah, that's literal.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's literal.
They're immediately adjacent to
these highly secure facilities.
PERSON: Why don't they
just put them inside?
WOMAN: But allowed in.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
they are allowed in.
Yeah.
Right.
There are just some
security issues, and--
STEPH: --side of a
mountain, literally?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
STEPH: And it's quite steep.
So, if you're walking
and you trip, like,
you would fall very
[LAUGH] heavily.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
It's very beautiful.
Great views.
STEPH: They have a great
view the bay and the bridge.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Remember,
we talked about Ernest Lawrence?
This is his lab.
Right?
Lawrence Berkeley Laboratory.
STUDENT: My only
concern would be,
if the technology's too early,
they'll be based on, like,
the people who they
know, instead of
the actual technology.
So what would be interesting is
if it's already technology that
shows some promise,
that way it's
kind of like a pseudo
right-before scale-up,
where it's, I need to get my
technical abilities scaled up?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
STUDENT: That'll be really good.
But the issue is, like, this
happens kind of like at MIT
with, like, Delta-V,
where it's like,
it's kind of become a
Sloane-y kind of like hub,
where it's like, there's people
who don't have great ideas,
but they apply because they
know the right person who does
if they go through,
versus, like--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This is
a very tough-minded selection
process.
You know?
Ilan is a real talent.
He's running a
good process, here.
Look, we're kind of running out
of time, here, so let me just
get the rest of the story out.
Because part of it, Martn,
speaks to the next issue
we've got, which is--
one of the issues here is,
these are all early stage.
Right?
These are very talented
technology teams, right out
of university laboratories.
Here's a different model.
TechBridge, right
here in Boston,
is part of the Boston
Fraunhofer system.
And they have a different
model, but they're similarly
providing this technology,
equipment, know-how-rich space
as a substitute for VC money.
And the idea here
is, Cyclotron Road
starts with the
technology group and then
tries to nurture the technology.
TechBridge starts with
large regional companies.
And it goes to them, and
it says, what do you want?
Right?
And, typically, they don't
want disruptive stuff
that's going to
wreck their business
model-- for obvious reasons.
And they don't want to bother
with stuff that they're already
doing, that they
understand well.
But there are substantial groups
of adjacent energy technologies
that fit with their model, that
would be interesting to them.
And that's what TechBridge
tries to find out.
So it gets a list of,
what do you folks want?
And then it goes to find
talented startups in the Boston
area, of which there's a lot,
and connect the right startup
to the right industry player,
for a collaborative project.
OK?
Very different model.
Very interesting.
The most interesting
part of it is
that those folks work
together for a little while.
They come up with kind of
the prototype together.
Right?
But industry doesn't
quite trust the startup.
The startup doesn't
know whether it's
going to get robbed
by the big company.
Who knows, right?
They bring in the
Fraunhofer laboratories,
this famous laboratory system,
and the Fraunhofer labs
do, for the
startup-industry combo,
what they do for
German companies.
They do a very tough-minded
technology assessment.
They break down the
technology, they evaluate it--
Can this technology
be manufactured?
How would you manufacture it?
Can you manufacture
it at a price that
would actually be saleable?
You know, is this
resilient technology?
All the kind of stuff they
do for German companies,
they're doing for the startup.
It's a very rich, sophisticated
technology evaluation process.
We don't really have
anything in our system
like it, so it's
pretty intriguing.
And, in effect, they
certify to the company--
I mean, they may say, this stuff
is worthless, throw it away,
or they could say, this is
actually very interesting.
Here's how you could
make it, and here's
the components you ought to
use and the materials you
ought to think about, and here's
a pathway to a marketplace.
The company, the
big company, loves
this, because they realize
the startup may not
be totally crazy.
And then the startup likes
it because, in effect, it's
certified their technology.
So this puts both players into
a much more informed space.
And that's been very--
it's been very
intriguing, sort of adding
this technology-validation
piece to this.
Remember, we talked
about the role of FDA
in certifying technology,
which guarantees a market?
This is the first time
I've seen this played out
in a US kind of model.
And it's kind of intriguing.
And I'll put one more
on the table for you.
That's Greentown Labs, a
respected, quite capable energy
incubator, full of
folks like you--
you know, off the lab
bunch at a school,
with cool energy
technology ideas.
Greentown began
understanding that there
are 60-odd teams, had a
lot of neat research ideas.
They had no idea
to make anything.
Right?
No idea.
You know, you weren't taught
how to make things, here at MIT.
Although it is changing
with the Maker movement.
But--
University-lab-originated
technology teams
don't know anything
about manufacturing.
So they had an interesting idea.
There's a manufacturing
extension program.
Every state has one, sponsored
by the Department of Commerce
NIST.
Massachusetts happens
to have a good--
quite a good manufacturing
extension program.
Greentown and the
MEP got together.
And the MEP said, hmm,
that's interesting.
We've never worked
with startups before.
We work with small
manufacturers.
But maybe we could link small
manufacturers and the startups.
And Massachusetts happens to
have still a pretty strong base
of small manufacturers.
They work for the defense
sector, the growing robotics
sector, the medical-device
sector-- which
are big sectors,
in Massachusetts,
and there's some
talented small companies.
The MEP ran a survey of its
capable small manufacturers.
And the survey
results came back.
83 were interested in
talking to startups.
Why?
These small manufacturers are
tied to existing supply chains.
They don't innovate.
They don't do R&E. They don't
have access to innovation.
How are they going to grow
their market significantly?
They're kind of
locked into a pathway.
This is a route out,
for some of them.
In addition, others like
the startup culture.
They thought,
that's pretty cool.
Let's get my employees
feeling like that.
Right?
Maybe we'll get some stuff done.
And some others thought,
gee, the startup culture's
important, now, in
Massachusetts, to its feature
acc--
[AUDIO OUT] We're good citizens.
We're going to help them.
So they created
this complex process
of how to arrange
these exchanges.
Now, the startups, they
communicate by internet things
that you all understand
and I have no idea.
Of.
Right?
I don't what they are.
But that's how they communicate.
You know, I'm
exaggerating, here,
but the startups by and
large voted for Bernie,
and the small manufacturers--
I'm exaggerating--
probably voted for Donald.
And they worked by
face-to-face meetings--
things like telephones.
You know?
You remember landlines?
They still exist.
These are completely
different cultures.
How are they going to fall
in love with each other
and be able to trust each
other to do technology
development together?
And there were no
incentives, here.
There were no subsidies.
The startup had to
come up with money,
to fund the advanced prototype
or the pilot production they
wanted to undertake.
So there were no giveaways
to incentivize people.
This was real money, and
both sides were at stake.
So they arranged this
four-step process,
to try and bring
about communication.
43 startups were interested.
After a year of pilot
projects, 19 deals.
Money changed hands.
Things were being made.
Pretty interesting.
So this is another piece.
We've now collected a
bunch of ideas, here.
Right?
Bunch of ideas, here, that
are potentially relevant--
From Cyclotron Road,
repurposing an existing source
of strong technology
equipment and know-how,
repurpose these energy labs.
That's a really
interesting idea,
because that's fairly cheap.
Right?
You don't have to build
all this new equipment.
MIT is doing the same
thing with equipment
it's got, for the engine.
From TechBridge, the
idea of, maybe you
could do this-- maybe you
could connect up companies
at the outset, with startups.
That's interesting.
And maybe you could do a
technology validation step.
And then this
third piece, here--
and then I'll call it a day and
let Chris lead some questions.
But this third piece,
here, is, maybe
you could tie small
manufacturers and startups,
because they both have a problem
that the other side could
solve.
Right?
So you start to see a
pretty interesting model
for Rafael's idea of
substituting space
for venture funding.
This is an interesting model.
Universities could
do this model.
MIT is trying to experiment
to show other schools that it
could be done.
Federal labs are
already pursuing this.
And the DOD has 67 of
these, and Lincoln Lab
is extremely interested in
this model, for example.
So is Draper, just
up the street.
So, in other words, there are
ways this thing could scale.
Right?
So, between universities
and existing laboratory
capabilities-- and then MIT's
got the idea of connecting you
to companies and nodes
that could help you
as you develop a more
sophisticated product line.
So there could be
a new model, here,
that would really
help with what's
become now a very significant
gap in US innovation system,
over the collapse of
venture-capital funding
for other than software,
biotech, and certain service
sectors.
Chris, it's all yours.
CHRIS: Awesome.
So I thought this is a
really interesting article,
because you often hear
about, oh, energy, funding,
and the whole system's
not really working,
but it was kind of hard for
me, at least, to see why,
and, like, the discussion of
the neoclassical economic model
and why that doesn't
really work out,
especially for this
kind of industry,
was pretty interesting to me.
So the way I saw it was that--
So there's kind of
a twofold problem.
Like, we have problems in energy
revolution and the technology
space and then also,
like, implementing
those technologies.
And Reif presents this
innovation-orchards kind
of framework, which
is really interesting.
And, as Bill mentioned, we
have a somewhat robust kind
of model for early, maybe
like incubator-type startups.
And then we have to somehow
bridge that gap to innovation.
I was just wondering, what
are your thoughts on how
we can kind of create
that smooth transition
between institutions that might
be providing some early seed
funding and then how
to transition those
into later stage, whether
those be connected
to, like, TechBridge or those
other models that have kind
of demonstrated some
pretty good ways to bring
that implementation
process into play.
RASHID: I think two things.
One, I was pretty astonished
at the first piece,
particularly taking this
neoclassical view of,
hey, should we do cap-and-trade
instead of carbon tax
[INAUDIBLE] for
curbing emissions?
And I think it did a pretty good
job of saying that maybe, like,
it's more complicated than that,
but also like the fact that we
were still looking to do sort
of a cap-and-trade system,
even in 2010, which
is relatively recent,
and classical economics has
existed for a while now--
made me think,
like, is economics--
Are the solutions that
we think theoretically,
like, in economics,
are they effectual?
And are they just kind of
limiting us, because we only
have this school
of economic thought
that says this is sort
of our solution subset,
this is the answer?
And are there
economists out there
aren't neoclassical
economists, that
may have solutions for us
that exist outside of--
that probably would be a lot
more palatable and useful
than a carbon tax or a
cap-and-trade system.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So, Rasheed, let
me build on that for
a second and just--
and, just to be clear,
don't get me wrong,
I do think a pricing
mechan-- there is definitely
a place for a pricing mechanism.
It can help a lot.
I think part of
the problem, here,
is that neoclassical
economics, as we talked about
in the first class, hasn't been
able to develop an outlook that
enables it to treat technology
innovation as endogenous
to economic-growth theory.
Right?
So SOLO announces
it's exogenous,
because it's too complex a model
for us to track the variables.
And, as we've talked
about in this class,
it involves history and
culture and organization theory
and all kinds of
other things that
are kind of outside the
parameters of what economics
is normally able to
track in its curves.
So that's a genuine problem.
So when neoclassical economics
comes up with a fix to climate,
it misses the technology side.
Because it doesn't
have sophisticated
handles to deal with it.
Now, obviously economists
like Romer and others
are attempting to make
technology theory endogenous,
part of economic
theory, but that's still
an ongoing project.
But that's where we
ran into trouble,
was that the technology need
over an extended period of time
didn't match the timetable
on cap-and-trade.
And the solution there was
to push off cap-and-trade.
And that's, in effect,
what we've done.
I still think we need
to come back to it,
but I think the
project at hand is
a technology-development
project and really
a state and local government
technology-implementation
alternatives, where
we could come up
with a Plan B that helped make
progress for the next decade
or so.
STEPH: I also, to add
to Rasheed's point,
I think that's what I
was getting at last week,
with my point about nonmarket
solutions to market--
to problems that
we're approaching
through the lens of economics,
in the sense that, perhaps
if we think about--
if we start our problem-solving
from a lens of promoting
social good, rather than
increasing capital gain,
then we might be able to come up
with alternative and innovative
solutions.
Right?
And so I think that's
sort of where--
Reif?
STUDENT: Reif.
STEPH: Reif was coming
from, that this model--
and I mentioned this on our
very first day of class--
very much is
similar to the model
that nongovernmental
organizations and nonprofits
have been using for a
very long time, in sort
of trading or leveraging
the kindness of individuals
and their willingness
to let them participate
in their spaces.
And you see this happen
for political campaigns.
Volunteer fellows
will go, and they
will live in a
supporter's house,
and then they will go on
and knock on people's doors
for that candidate.
And they will do so for very
little money or no money
at all.
And so, as someone who comes
from the nonprofit and NGO
sector, and I've been
you know volunteering
in politics since I
was really little,
the ways in which you can
leverage on the sort of good
and ethics of people seems to
me a much more interesting place
to start for research
and development
and for hardware technologies
than people would think.
Because, if you approach it
from a lens of economics,
it's very difficult
to make the case,
oftentimes, that your
technology could be disruptive
and could pay off.
But if you approach it
from a lens of social good,
it's possible that
you could appeal
to the ethos of a
venture capitalist.
Because, for example,
someone like Bill Gates
is more likely to
say, I want to do this
because I think it's
the right thing to do,
than to make the argument that
it's a good investment for him
and that the ROI
will be greater.
So I think that there is a
benefit to sometimes pivoting
away from market-oriented
problem-solving
and to view it from a different
sort of lens of ethics
or social-good promotion.
Obviously that won't always
work, but there are instances,
and I think this is
one, in which that
is where we are leaning toward.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And I will
add, Steph, to your point,
that part of what has
come with the engine
is a bridge fund available
to those startups.
So Rafael and
colleagues have been
able to raise over, I
think, $150 million,
now, for commitments
to a bridge fund.
Because, you know,
these startups
are going to need some funding.
Right?
It's not going to--
they save huge expenses by
equipment and technology
and know-how savings,
in this new space,
but they still are going
to need to get funding.
And so this bridge fund
could really help them.
That money was raised
from, essentially,
generous rich people
in this region, who
were prepared to, in effect,
make a charitable donation
towards this thing,
thinking that it might
be helpful to the
overall innovation
economy in the
Massachusetts area.
And they have an
opportunity for return.
So, if these startups
take off, there
is an opportunity for return.
But, frankly, they're
not expecting it.
So that has actually worked.
And Rafael has just
been able to demonstrate
that you can raise money on the
basis of that kind of approach.
STEPH: And I think they're
one of the interesting models.
And perhaps you've
looked at this.
Maybe you haven't.
But it's the way in
which art museums
and, in particular,
contemporary art museums
pursue funding from
philanthropists.
Because it's often that a lot
of the contemporary artists that
are sort of on the
leading edge are something
that people are very
reticent to adopt.
So the museums that
purchase their art,
either for their
permanent collections
or for their temporary
exhibits, often
allow their philanthropists
to gain some sort of benefit
or value from having
hosted that and having
attached their name to it.
And, later on, it
is that, because art
is seen as a commodity
and luxury good,
they're able to sort of gain
capital return on it, as well.
So I think it could
be interesting to look
at the ways in which museums
and art museums specifically
do their philanthropy
for technology.
CHRIS: Sure.
Go ahead.
STUDENT: Well, I think there's--
OK.
There is also, like,
purely private-sector
market-driven models.
I think a really good example
is Autodesk., so right down here
by the seaport.
And--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Why
don't you describe it.
STUDENT: Yeah.
So, Autodesk, they
basically want
to become the software
company for any CAD, CNC,
anything that you want to make.
And so they have a fellowship
program here, and then--
so Auto-- they're MIT
startups who work in their
build space at the
innovation building.
And they also-- like, Pier 9 is,
like, probably the best maker
space in the world.
And they have
[INAUDIBLE] come in.
For them, they get a
lot of value out of it,
because these innovators
are testing their software
and pushing it to its
limits and giving them
ideas for new features.
Also, when those
startups hit market,
Autodesk really helped
make that possible.
So there's a lot
of benefit to them.
And they give these people
working on hard technologies
a really great working space
to develop their stuff.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Chris,
do you want to give us
a few closing thoughts on this?
CHRIS: Yeah, sure.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You had
some very perceptive opening
comments.
CHRIS: Cool.
Yeah.
So, I think one thing we didn't
really get a chance to touch on
was that climate change and,
like, the whole energy sector
is kind of a different beast
from a lot of different kind
of sectors, because
the way you evaluate
how "good" a technology is,
is kind of a much longer time
span than, say, I don't
know, biotech, where you can
immediately see the impacts.
I mean, the drug works or not.
Right?
You can immediately tell.
But, for climate change,
sure, you can, I don't know,
measure carbon emissions year
by year or something like that.
But then you run the
risk of, policies,
social mindset, or
whatever, shifting,
once maybe you get on a trend
of seeing some improvement,
and then you might just
shift and completely erase
what you've done in
the past year or so.
So, definitely, the longer time
span makes it more difficult,
not only for funding but
also, like, development,
implementation.
And I think a lot
of these new models,
like the innovation
orchards, TechBridge,
these models are
really cool and should
be interesting to see
how they play out.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Great.
Martha, do you want to give us a
thought from MITI's perspective
about some of these new models?
MARTHA: So-- well,
I guess that--
Bill, you kind of
caught me by surprise.
I've been holding back--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Sorry.
MARTHA: That's OK!
That's all right.
I think-- well, first
of all, Chris just
touched on something
really important,
which is that one of
the big challenges--
and I think I've
mentioned this before--
is that, traditionally,
energy technologies take
decades to get adopted.
And just the pie chart
on the VCs [LAUGH]
tells you something about
what energy technologies are
competing against for capital.
I guess that this
is a great model,
if it could get
replicated, you know,
and even break through
energy ventures, which
is a different model.
I mean, this is an earlier
stage, helping people get past.
It feels like
things move slowly.
And, like everything related
to this whole energy challenge,
we need to kind of
pick up the pace.
And, Bill, you talked
about the states
and that there's
different players.
It's challenging.
Right?
I mean, the states just
don't have the kind of--
first of all, they compete
against each other.
They also just don't
have the resources.
So we'll see where we end up.